JP Rangaswami
JP: Yes I think China will actually help pull
us out of the economic crisis we're in, but
for reasons that may be different from what
is perceived. Fundamentally, we need innovation
to get us out of this crisis. We can't use
the paradigm of the old or rules of the old
in order to be able to solve the problems
of the old. Innovation is key and I think
that the role that China plays because talent
knows no voters is going to be absolutely
critical. The place that innovation has to
take place is going to really involve the
sector I'm in, which is, you know, communications
and again I think, because of not just the
talent for it but because of our ability to
understand and work with skill, China is going
to be absolutely critica. So the answer may
not be quite what you guys were expecting.
I think China has a key role to play on it,
the role is associated with how talent innovates
and how communications plays a role or not.